I choose the NPM program because I've
always been interested in technology I'm
a choose Stanford because of the
innovation and entrepreneurship and the
good ecosystem you have right kind of
stuff here and of course the climate I
love going new places and I really enjoy
the experience of meeting new people
Stanford is really good at bringing out
professors to classes and you actually
get a chance to interact with them and
learn from their experiences in addition
to you know joining a great university
I've had opportunity to also experience
on the part of Californian life riding
motorcycle with meeting a lot of new
friends in that way culture here our own
motorcycles are very special I think
there's a long tradition of writing in
groups getting to know other people
people are very friendly open so I made
a lot of friends and also I've got
opportunity to then see the life outside
the university well I'm sitting here now
it's end of May I'm sitting shorts I've
been wearing shorts for almost the
entire experience
oh my god here in January so that's one
big key the better the climate but of
course I was enticed to to learn more
about what everybody hears about Silicon
Valley and what's actually in the secret
sauce that everybody's talking about so
if you're coming to Stanford there are a
couple of things that you really should
do the first one is to get a bite
because there's no way to get around
here without one the second one is to
use the opportunities that present
themselves here to do networking which I
find to be a fantastic experience here
you have like a 70 year history of
entrepreneurship you have a whole
community of angel investors VCS and
preneur innovators and you don't have
something like that or anything like
that then in
Europe or at least not in Norway so
that's impressed me I would say my
experience at Stanford is basically all
about sharing and you see it in every
class you see it when you talk to the
professor's after class and it's all
about sharing ideas and sharing friends
sharing relations to help each other to
the next big thing prime reason to go to
Stanford is if you're interested in
entrepreneurship and innovation then you
should come here you definitely should
come here because this is the hot spot
for it's in the States
and I go also in the globe and you meet
people from everywhere here so so
definitely recommend it but be aware
it's a lot of math there so you have to
be good with numbers